[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Serien guten Abend ihnen allen
Norbert König hat gleich das Wichtigste
vom Sport ja schönen Abend nach dem
Abzug russischer Truppen sind
schockierende Kriegsbilder aufgetaucht
und damit beginnt unser Überblick
weltweites Entsetzen nach mutmaßlichen
grolltaten der russischen Armee verlangt
die Bundesregierung Aufklärung
spannende Parlamentswahl in Ungarn ein
breites Oppositionsbündnis fordert
premier Orban heraus
und Spitzen spielen der Frauen
Bundesliga im Dauerduell deklassiert
Wolfsburg die Bayern mit sechs zu null
entsetzliche Kriegsbilder aus einem
Vorort von Kiew erschüttern nicht nur
die internationale Politik zu sehen
zahlreiche Leichen offenbar vom
russischen Militär hingerichtete
Zivilisten manche von ihnen gefesselt
die Bilder so brutal dass es weltweit
ein Echo des Entsetzens gibt
Bundeskanzler Scholz spricht von
Kriegsverbrechen und kündigt neue
Sanktionen an Volker Duczek und
Christian Volk
es sind Bilder von Chaos und Leid
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge in Butscher
ineinander verkeilt russische
ukrainische jetzt da die Russen in Ort
nördlich von Kia verlassen haben kehrt
die Bevölkerung zurück und sieht Bilder
die man kam aushalten kann tote mitten
auf der Straße Männer Frauen Kinder die
meisten sollen Zivilisten sein bisher
weiß man nicht viel darüber wie sie zu
Tode kam einige sollen gefesselt gewesen
sein sagen ukrainische
Regierungsvertreter
die Nationalpolizei schiebt Autos von
der Straße sie vermutet überall Minen
und Sprengfallen auch an den Leichnamen
der Getöteten Einwohner das entsetzten
weltweit für die Opfer einnahmenloses
Massengrab die Staatsanwaltschaft
spricht am Abend von 410 Toten in
Butcher und den umliegenden Dörfern die
deutsche Bundesregierung will dass die
Verantwortlichen zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden die Ermordung von
Zivilisten ist ein Kriegsverbrechen
diese Verbrechen der russischen
Streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange das
internationale Organisationen wie das
Internationale Komitee vom Roten Kreuz
Zugang erhalten zu diesen Gebieten und
die Gräueltaten dokumentieren die
ukrainische Regierung nennt es
Völkermord verlangt neue schärfere
Sanktionen gegen Russland
in der Ukraine haben wir mehr als 100
Nationalitäten hier geht es um die
Zerstörung und Vernichtung all dieser
Nationalitäten
das Verteidigungsministerium in Moskau
bezeichnet die Videos als Fälschung die
russischen Truppen hätten die Vororte
Kiews schon am Mittwoch verlassen und
erst jetzt vier Tage später würde dieses
gefälschte Bildmaterial auftauchen im
Bild sei nur Schauspieler zu sehen
behauptet Moskau
wir gehen nach Berlin zu Schack
runterladen
Kanzler Scholz hat auf die Gräueltaten
sehr schnell sehr direkt reagiert was
könnte das bedeuten ja das könnte
bedeuten dass da auch für ihn eine rote
Linie überschritten gewesen ist beim
Anschauen dieser Bilder die Frage ist
allerdings was folgt daraus Vizekanzler
Habeck und Außenministerin baerbock
haben schon angekündigt dass jetzt über
schärfere Sanktionen geredet werden muss
auch Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
hat gesagt im europäischen Verbund müsse
man jetzt zum Beispiel über einen
gas-stopp diskutieren aber Olaf Scholz
Scholz selbst ist eben in seinem
Statement da etwas ungenauer geblieben
er hat gesagt man werde jetzt mit den
europäischen Partnern weitere Maßnahmen
besprechen und die Folgen würde Putin
auch spüren ob dazu auch das um in
Deutschland umstrittene Energie embargo
gehört dass es nicht klar da hat sich
die Bundesregierung ja bisher gegen
gesperrt ob sie angesichts dieser Bilder
und das sicherlich steigenden Drucks aus
Europa dabei bleiben kann das wird sich
zeigen danke Shark runterladen mehr zum
Thema auch nach uns mit dir in Berlin
direkt unter anderem mit einem Robert
Habeck Interview vielen Dank jetzt zur
spannenden Parlamentswahl nach Ungarn es
geht auch um die politische Zukunft des
Amtsinhabers Ministerpräsident Orban
regiert ununterbrochen seit zwölf Jahren
das Land in seiner Amtszeit wurde die
Unabhängigkeit der Medien und der
justizmassiv eingeschränkt ihm gegenüber
ein breites Oppositionsbündnis von
rechts bis links vereint in dem Ziel
Orban abzuwählen ihr Spitzenkandidat ist
Peter Markise über die Richtungswahl
jetzt wolf-christian Ulrich
Ministerpräsident Viktor Orban gab seine
Stimme heute früh in Budapest ab ich
erwarte einen großen Sieg das ist das
was dieses Land braucht
im System Orban ist alles auf diesen
großen Sieg ausgerichtet Presse
Wirtschaft Machtapparat Russlands Krieg
wurde für putinpartner Orban im
Wahlkampf zum Problem er versucht sich
zwischen Ost und West zu positionieren
seine Wähler goutieren das
ich bin zwar nicht komplett zufrieden
mit der Regierung aber ich finde das in
der aktuellen Situation Orbans fides
Partei besser ist
die sechs wichtigsten
Oppositionsparteien treten bei dieser
Wahl gemeinsam an um eine Chance gegen
Orban zu haben
ich möchte ein Ungarn wo die jungen
Leute auch bleiben können Arbeit finden
und zumindest annähernd Gehälter auf
westlichem Niveau bekommen
Spitzenkandidat Peter marquisoy ein
konservativer Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
kämpft gegen die Korruption des
orban-systems außerdem ist die
Opposition klar pro EU Marky sol gab
heute morgen in seinem süd-ungarischen
Heimatort die Stimme ab
wir kämpfen für Demokratie und Anstand
für die Unabhängigkeit der Justiz und
für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Ungarn
in Budapest drenten heute Vormittag
viele Menschen in die Wahllokale doch
insgesamt liegt die Wahlbeteiligung
etwas niedriger als vor vier Jahren mit
verlässlichen Ergebnissen wird erst am
späteren Abend gerechnet
dann jetzt live nach Budapest zu Britta
Hilpert Britta wonach sieht es aktuell
aus
ja sicher ist schon mal dass diese etwas
niedrigere Wahlbeteiligung kein Plus ist
für die Opposition das hätte ihr genutzt
wenn mehr Leute zur Wahl gegangen sind
und es gibt auch weitere kleinere
Hinweise darauf dass es vielleicht für
Orban wieder reicht es ist noch
überhaupt nicht verlässlich in Ungarn
gibt es keine exit-ports es gibt keine
Befragung nach den Wahllokal aber hier
im Pressesaal macht das schon die Runde
dass es wohl für Orban gerade noch
gereicht hat vielleicht nicht mit einer
verfassungsändernden zwei Drittel mehr
hat und das ehrlich gesagt wäre schon
eine Sensation dann Orban hat die Jahre
an der Regierung natürlich auch dazu
genutzt das Wahlrecht zu sein Gunsten zu
ändern so dass seine Partei wie das
immer beurteilt wird so ist es ihm
gelungen beim letzten Mal mit rund 49
Prozent der Stimmen eine zwei
drittelmehrheit im Parlament zu erringen
es wäre also für die Opposition schon
ein Erfolg wenn sie wenigstens diese
zwei Drittel Mehrheit von fides brechen
könnte aber das ist noch nicht klar ob
aus der Opposition gelungen ist es auch
noch nicht klar ob es wirklich gereicht
hat auch für Orban denn wie Wolf
Christian Ulrich schon sagte
verlässliche Ergebnisse gibt es erst in
einigen Stunden man darf gespannt sein
danke live aus Budapest war das Britta
Hilpert gewählt wird auch im Nachbarland
Serbien die Stimmberechtigten sind
aufgerufen das Parlament und den
Präsidenten zu wählen dabei wird die
Wiederwahl des amtierenden Nationalisten
wucic erwartet wichtigste Herausforderer
der frühere Militärchef Bonus der von
der proeuropäischen Opposition
unterstützt wird
sehr umstritten mit dem heutigen Tag
fallen fast überall in Deutschland die
corona-schutzmaßnahmen außer im
Krankenhäusern und öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln braucht es keine Masken
bzw 3 oder 2g-regeln mehr allerdings
können Betriebe von ihrem Hausrecht
Gebrauch machen und selber bestimmen aus
Bayern Petra Neubauer
letzte Lagebesprechung im
Trachtengeschäft von Maria Reiter in
Rosenheim heute ist verkaufsoffener
Sonntag und das ohne
corona-beschränkungen erst einmal ein
gutes Gefühl grundsätzlich ist es für
uns natürlich Schuhe Erleichterung wenn
man nicht acht Stunden oder länger
permanent die Maske tragen müssen
dennoch wolle man hier flexibel
reagieren wenn gewünscht mit Maske
bedienen die Kunden an diesem ersten Tag
gespalten ich werde die Maske die
nächste Zeit so aufsetzen wie ich sie
vorher auch aufgesetzt habe
uns gelesen ich denke jetzt ist der
Zeitpunkt an dem es einfach das Risiko
überschaubar ist dabei liegt die
Inzidenz in Rosenheim noch immer bei
rund 2000 die Impfquote bei nur 66
Prozent Infektiologen warnen viele
Menschen denken nun mit Aufhebung der
maskenpflicht ist die Pandemie vorbei
und dem ist nicht so ich halte es für
irreführend
heißt auch öffentlich Dinge sehr sehr
stark zu lockern eine M
Ken von laut einer Umfrage nur etwa 12
Prozent der bayerischen Händler
Ausstellungszentrum Lokschuppen hält man
davon trotz so vieler Besucher heute
nicht
da reagieren die Leute ungehalten drauf
wir stellen es den Leuten frei unsere
Besucher machen es ungefähr halbe halbe
gerade viel Eigenverantwortung ist also
gefragt offen bleibt allerdings ob das
funktioniert
so jetzt geht es hier bei uns sportlich
weiter und Norbert König übernimmt ja
mit einem herben Dämpfer für den FC
Bayern und zwar für die Frauen denn in
der Bundesliga jubeln heute die
Wolfsburgerinnen nach dem sechs zu null
gegen den amtierenden Meister aus
München hat der VfL Wolfsburg drei
Spiele vor Schluss vier Punkte Vorsprung
und damit beste Chancen auf den siebten
deutschen Meistertitel
den Anfang der Wolfsburger torserie
macht Svenja Huth bereits nach 8 Minuten
nach dem Führungstreffer der
Gastgeberinnen ist das Spiel für eine
knappe halbe Stunde offen doch noch vor
der Pause erhöhen erst Joel Wedemeyer
und dann Tabea Wasmuth zum 3:0 für die
tabellenführerinnen die Münchnerinnen
haben auch in der zweiten Hälfte dem
Wolfsburger Tor Trang nichts
entgegenzusetzen im Gegenteil
Alexandra Popp mit dem 4:0 gegen die
Titelverteidigerinnen die nach dem
Champions League aus gegen Paris
Saint-Germain und vielen Corona
bedingten Ausfällen sehr müde wirken und
es kommt noch schlimmer Lena Oberdorf
und dann noch in der Nachspielzeit Eva
pajor sorgen für den 6:0 entstand und
damit für eine mehr als deutliche
Vorentscheidung im Kampf um die deutsche
Meisterschaft
die Wolfsburger Männer haben heute
nichts zu feiern der FC Augsburg gewinnt
im ersten Sonntagsspiel klar mit 3 zu 0
und hat jetzt drei Punkte Vorsprung auf
die Abstiegsränge nach dem Wechselfehler
des FC Bayern beim SC Freiburg die
Männer haben die Verantwortlichen der
Breisgauer noch nicht über einen
Einspruch entschieden der bis morgen
nachmittag eingelegt werden müsste die
Bayern hatten gestern für ein paar
Sekunden mit zwölf Spielern auf dem
Platz gestanden und spannendes Finale
nach 273 Kilometern bei der
Flandernrundfahrt im Zielsprint holt
sich der Niederländer Mathieu van der
Pool zum zweiten Mal den Sieg beim
Frühjahrsklassiker in Belgien vor seinem
Landsmann Dillen van barle Ärger dagegen
bei Tour de France Sieger Tadday
pogatscha der sich vor pokert und am
Ende nur Vierter wird
bei so einem kann man sagen nur Vierter
vielen Dank für Norbert wir werfen noch
schnell einen Blick aufs Wetter und das
geht so im Norden kräftiger Regen im
Osten und im berglandteils mit Schnee
vermischt dazu starker Südwestwind mit
schweren Sturmböen im Süden trocken und
sonnige Abschnitte vier bis zehn Grad
auch in den nächsten Tagen nass und
windig allerdings wird es dann wieder
ein bisschen milder
wir empfehlen noch das heute journal mit
Christian Sievers 21:45 Uhr geht's los
wir fangen heute 19 Themen sind morgen
wieder für Sie da schönen Dank fürs
zuschauen einen schönen Sonntag